i'm carol stone i ran a think tank
called you gotta tell which brings
together people of influence to discuss
the socialism that matter to us all and
I'm so Anna Club bringing people
together to debate issues of music to us
all my first time at Davos I'm here to
write an article for The Spectator and I
also a counselor for one young world and
here are a dual role I want to answer
the question what keeps me motivated and
what keeps me motivated is really the
lion I suppose that my mother gave to me
which was keep looking around the corner
you never know what's around the corner
and also know that whatever happens you
can cope and I think I'm motivated by
wanted to stretch my potential and
there's nothing like divorce to bring
together such fascinating people in the
sessions you learn things and then in
the corridors and outside you can take
that conversation forward so that's
what's going to make one in Britain
where Quinn the big society making sure
that we can improve the way we live by
listening to the experts talking to each
other that's what life is all about your
friendship bringing people together is
the joy of life and the boss is doing it
absolutely perfectly and I'm delighted
to be here